[Music]
I um I should have dressed up I I just
thought we were going to go
eat this is how I hang this is how I see
my friends these days you know what I
mean it actually legit is very good to
see you but normally it is in some sort
of vegan Diner yes are you still vegan
I've been I've been doing that uh for
energy purposes mostly for the show are
you you know what I wanted to know are
you still meditating uh not as much
interesting question because I find that
I need to be stressed out to do the show
a little bit I I got into a nice deep
meditation before a taping once and I
went out and I was too Zen I was like
laugh or don't laugh either way yeah the
world is on fire who cares you know what
I mean yeah it's all passing are you you
uh yeah but not as much do you get
bothered when I call you as Dave
Chappelle what sometimes I oh yeah no
I've called you and M a horrible Dave
Chappelle impression it's not that bad
it's pretty bad n n call me
baby I want to do season four change my
mind all right
now they backed away so much they backed
away okay now do your
aiz call me baby H sh said do4 yeah it's
the same thing yeah Ross perau uh
yeah
[Music]